this is really important conversation to
have especially now more than ever uh
you know talking about mental health but
never did I imagine that we would have
this conversation with twitch not here
and so I just want to ask as friends of
his how are you guys holding up holding
up I mean it's it's a really sad
unfortunate I'm hoping that it can be
used as a reminder to people that life
is precious and uh and you never know
it's best to just continue to reach out
to the people that you love and um
trying as much as possible
um help them feel like
speaking and being around you is a safe
space and then you know be be a support
system and and be whatever somebody
needs and help them uh find the tools
that that they can use November is a
fantastic organization just for that
purpose this campaign is so important
insurance I know you actually posted you
know from where we stood your light
shines so brightly we had no idea that
from where you stood there was no light
left so talk to me about this campaign
and how I don't know it's kind of
informed you about the complexities of
mental health because sometimes it's not
so black and white or clear as day gosh
I've been an advocate for mental health
for a long time I've had my own Journey
with it I think many of us have but to
know that
someone that you would never ever expect
and this is what we've seen people
saying the last few days you would never
have imagined and so I think the best
thing that we can do and what I love
about movember is it opens up authentic
conversations and I think for us as
people and humans in our everyday life
we have to live by example with that
with being authentic in ourselves and
allowing people to be themselves and not
feel like they have to be this light or
they have to be this Persona sometimes
for everybody else but allow them to be
their authentic self and know that it's
okay to not always be shining so
brightly
um and I think that's a really important
message and sometimes it's difficult to
say those things to people that you love
or in your circle I think unfortunately
suicide
feels reasonable for a lot of people
because they don't have places to go
that can help them understand and
realize like oh no what it is you are
dealing with right now is not is not a
sane feeling it's not it's not the same
part of your brain having something like
movemba that gives a safe space uh for
people to go to to speak about these
things and thoughts and feelings I think
is so important for people to know
because sometimes speaking anonymously
to a person is the easiest thing to do
there's no shame in that conversation
you don't feel any
um because shame comes with these
feelings right when you're talking to
those that you love you can feel bad
about the way you feel for them
embarrassed whereas if you're speaking
anonymously to someone you there is
comfort and safety in that and I really
want people to know in this holiday
season those that are suffering with
loss or illness or financial hardship
that there is access to help in
conversation there to help them get
through this time and that's what you
guys are doing right you're raising
awareness you mentioned this Sharna
you're leading by example I mean even
just this week Sean are you posted about
having your own dark thoughts after
having Zayn you know why was it
important for you to kind of share that
story and what has the response been
like you know I it's interesting I felt
cold to share that because I went
through the experience of thinking is it
just me is it just me that has these is
there something wrong with my brain am I
heading into postpartum depression I
would ask is this normal and I did get
assured by Family by Bry
um that you know these sort of thoughts
are normal but I got to a point where it
was I was having thoughts of Bry not
making it home from work or my mum not
making it back to her house from leaving
our house and I had one panic attack and
that's when I went you know what I
absolutely need to see someone about
this because it's escalating and I
realized that every mum goes through
this and so some degree and then I also
read that 94 of people men and women
have intrusive thoughts and these and
it's a real term intrusive thoughts and
whether that is you don't deserve that
job or to the way more dramatic and more
violent versions of those thoughts
everybody needs to understand they're
not alone that these things are not
singular it is not just you in your own
world of horrible thoughts there are
people experiencing the same thing there
is a community that can welcome you in
and say you're not alone let's get
through this together and you can have
support from other people around you it
was a huge deal for me to know that I
was not alone and I think for people
especially on Instagram this
picture-perfect look of motherhood and
parenting and we all put up a highlight
reel and I think it's so refreshing to
know oh wow it's not what it looks like
I think there is comfort in knowing that
other people are going through that too
and so it was really important to share
I did not expect such a huge response
um for it to connect to so many people
and the stories that women shared with
me were so inspiring and heartbreaking
and I then realized just how important
it is for people to know that um we need
to normalize this conversation of
thoughts like this and take away the
shame of having them as soon as you
start realizing that you aren't alone
and that these are much more common
thoughts and feelings than you realize
then you start going okay it's not just
something wrong with me Sean is that
what you felt like when you heard all
these stories from these other women
that you could relate and that you
weren't alone was that part of the the
healing process for you at all was that
cathartic it was you know it's
unexpectedly very cathartic that post
and that sharing and I think I found an
even bigger Community online with the
mums in us sharing stories with each
other and responded to many of them and
said thank you for sharing because I
know that's a really big deal some of
these women shared stories that they
thought they were going to be the reason
for harm of their baby so they
considered taking their own life and
that really hit me that there was a baby
that was at risk of losing their mother
because they thought they were alone in
these thoughts and things uh so to know
that I allowed them to feel seen and
heard and and that opened up a
conversation for them it's just so
powerful sharing is so powerful it's one
of the beautiful things of social media
that we can get out of it and hopefully
we can use that platform and this and
speaking with yourself to let people
know there is access to mental health
and you are not alone it sounds like you
got the support from Brian too did you
feel seen in her when you shared I mean
this you know with him very very much so
since pregnancy into birth into
motherhood you know Briar has been an
incredible support for me and never
minimizing or dismissing when these
things come up always allowing me to
feel heard seen and supported and loved
and that is a really big deal and I'm
very very lucky that I have that tribe
of people around me that helps support
in parenting and motherhood and
recovering and I know not everybody has
that and I wish that they could have
what I have so this is again why it's so
important for people to know that there
is access to people that do want to help
and that will make you feel seen and
heard and understood